i really didn't i really didn't look at
myself as
a successful person i didn't see the
things that other people see
you know and then when i did you know i
was a narcissist and i was stuck up and
you know i've never been able to have a
happy medium ever you know
but i know the one good thing that i was
good at is
being a mom i was a good mom
and that's part of the that's part of
the reason why i get hurt so much out
here
you know is because i think that i'm
trying to
mother so many other people you know and
take them underneath my wing and then
they hurt me or
rob me or both you know and then next
thing you know i'm like oh my god i
believed in you
i believed in you when you didn't
believe in you
and this is how you repay me
but hey it is what it is
and it ain't what it ain't just like you
said not everybody is
is capable and there is good and there
is evil out here and i just so happen to
be
somebody that has good in them still you
know
you clearly had it at one point in your
life
and maybe you're losing your kids send
you
spiraling downward but absolutely
but that doesn't mean you can't get it
back absolutely with a little help a
little housing a little
right you know and only it only took
three years
and skid row and all kinds of things
but you're you're using crystal meth
less you're using you are using crystal
meth at all anymore not at all and
you're drinking a lot less right
a lot less yeah i'm trying
yeah that's great i'm trying
because when i
when i'm not gonna say if when i do
get off the streets right
i don't want the detox process to be so
painful
because i have detox from alcohol and
it's very painful
you know you're you're you get
restless leg syndrome you you feel
anxiety
you sweat you shake
it's pretty bad
so i don't want it to be so painful
because i've already wasted so much time
on the street in this bermuda triangle
of
[ __ ] skid row i swear it's from you
to trying it really
you fly over this [ __ ] and you'll never
be seen again ever
but um
like i had said before i am not i'm not
going out like that
i'll be damned i'll be damned
and because i do have a daughter right
and she's almost the same age that i was
i would really like to be
in her life you know i don't want any of
those things to happen to her that
happened to me
and even though my mom is not the same
person
you know she's still evil enough to take
my kids away from me and not let me see
them
you know knowing that that would ruin me
for a paycheck
so
they need me they need me especially my
baby girl
you know um boys need their moms too
you know but the girls especially need
their moms
healthier kids um
3 11 and 14.
um jeremiah therese and
christopher those are my babies
i named them all after something
you know because i believe that your
name has power
at least i believe that know that
christopher means with christ inside
your heart
so i named him that and he's just the
sweetest boy
with the big he looks like i climbed on
top of myself and got pregnant my son
he's got big green eyes just like me and
he has a sweetest spirit
and my daughter my daughter's my little
chocolate drop
and she looks just like me
but black and
um therese means reaper
you know like you know how it says you
reap what you sow not reaper like grim
reaper but
reaper like receiver you know
and that's also my mother's name because
my mother named me
after her mother so
i wanted to keep the legacy going i
guess
and um jeremiah is named after
a prophet in the bible
and he is a mighty little boy
he was nine pounds 22 and a half
inches they had to give me an emergency
c-section because
my heart rate was excelling and his
heart rate was dropping so they were
basically losing both of us
so they had to give me an emergency
c-section and that's
that was my little miracle baby that was
my sober baby that was my
yeah so
so you you've been on the street for how
long now three years
three years and you've been through it
all you've been beaten up you've been
raped robbed kidnapped
um tipped yes
all of that and you're finally climbing
out
are you ready to climb up absolutely
absolutely absolutely
i cannot i cannot
do this anymore see that's that's what
i was saying earlier um that i don't
believe
the majority of the people that i've
interviewed interviewed are even capable
of accepting
the the the let's say we did a donation
campaign for most of the people i talked
to
and they said here we're gonna get you
housing we're gonna get you rehab we're
gonna get you this that and the other
i don't believe those people would
actually be able to use it
they are very comfortable unless they
want it more than everyone else in their
life combined
they're just gonna find some excuse why
it's not working they've given up
and you what i'm hearing in your voice
is
you want this more than i do you
you want yeah because it's for me it
ain't for you
and that that's that's the important
part because i can want it my viewers
can want it as much as
you as you deserve it but if you don't
want it i want it what are we doing
and that's what that's why you're back
because i see that you actually
are capable and ready to do something
i have to
i have to because at this point because
you know good things are happening in my
life you know so that means that
the good is outweighing the bad now so
now the tables have been turned
and
just like god will never stop fighting
for me the devil won't either
because in all actuality i'm valuable to
both teams
even though that sounds bad it's true
you know so it's spiritual warfare and
they're both fighting for me
but i cannot let the devil win and i
won't
i'm all i was bought with the price a
long time ago and i'll never forget that
um so
what i did see with a lot of the
comments that i read right
thank you sweetheart what i did see with
a lot of the
comments that i read and there were a
lot of comments and
i thank all of you guys for
believing in me and for wanting to hug
me and
for wanting to help me and for your
words of encouragement
because i there were days where i would
just read all the comments and i would
remind myself that okay you know what
they have all these people in australia
and canada
and mississippi and everywhere else that
if they can believe in you why can't you
right that's exactly right so i had to
just keep reading
it's a really good sign when somebody
interview
reads or even engages in the comments
because
there have been people who i've
interviewed who everyone thinks
they're communicating with this person
but i know for a fact that that person
refuses to read all the positive
comments that are coming i tried to like
all of them
but there's like there's like 1200 or
something like
no you can't like them all but but just
reading them and
i've seen this very often where people
there's a sea of positivity coming their
way
love compassion positivity and they
won't even read it because it doesn't
fit into their
negative mindset their self-hate
so why would i want to read this
positivity these people that are saying
all these lovely wonderful things
loving things towards me it doesn't fit
their
self-image so they're going to reject it
one minute
right but when my old job right
and people that i hung out with got
drunk with and worked with for years
right one of the girls that
got a hold of me is my daughter's god
mom
and she's actually a co-owner of the
company that i used to work for
for years right
and this is a company one of the only
companies that actually believed in me
and dealt with my [ __ ]
you know but because
i'm very good at my job your [ __ ]
being like the alcohol
yeah i mean because i i've been
struggling i've been struggling with
this off and on
for a long time but you know not just
the alcohol but my temper and my
you know and my um
sense of entitlement and you know all
that stuff comes along with addiction it
really
does you know especially when you find
something that you're finally good at
you get cocky and all that other stuff
you know and
i was really good at my job you know so
i felt like i
was king kong you know so they dealt
with me going off
on the sales floor and all of that stuff
you know
um having no call no shows
you know just stupid stuff that any
other job would fire you for
but they they knew me when i had first
first had my baby
my oldest
i actually had actually because my
babysitter had flaked on me this is a
long time ago this is like in 2005.
my babysitter flaked on me so i had to
bring my baby with me to my interview
and like from that point on they just
fell in love with me
and i had two more kids while i was in
the company and
everything else and
they actually even opened up another
company in columbia
like there's good things going on
and they want me to be a part of it
again but you know everybody has their
own lives and their own [ __ ]
and their own bills to pay and
car payments and all that you know
it's hard to take on a whole other
person
can't just i know for sure that if you
could do it i know that you would
you know what i mean if you could
financially say hey hey look
here's this place we're taking you here
you're gonna work there you know i know
that you would do that
if you could but that's hard to do
especially if you don't know for sure
you have to see that somebody is going
to try
you know you have to you have to know
i appreciate you very much you know and
um
i've never had a a perfect stranger help
me the way that you've helped me
you know my own family has even
abandoned me
and i never understood
how much seeing yourself in your own
mess
could change your outlook on what's
going on really
around you you know you know how they
have that saying
um on the outside looking in
i actually got to do that and i used to
watch my video and
it would make me cry every single time
you know
it was therapeutic to me and i
appreciate you for that
this is not a game this is not a game
this is not this is not truth or dare
this is not a story
this is not [ __ ] make-believe this is
not
fiction this is my life
and i do not want to lose it out here
because one of two things are gonna
happen mark okay
because i've been trying my hardest
right to have so much compassion
and i do right but like i had said in my
previous interview because of all the
crap
that i've been going through right
and all the heartache and all the pain
and all the everything like
believing in people and people hurting
me and
all that stuff it's made me meaner
you know so i'm either gonna
hurt somebody like for real for real
and go to prison for the rest of my life
because i have all this built up
aggression on the inside of me
so if i were to ever just go
off oh my god
it would probably be bad you know
especially the way that i was drinking
because you know
at that point you get inebriated right
and then your emotions are
they um they're heightened you know
and you can start off just a little bit
pissed off but if you drunk enough oh
you turn into the [ __ ] hulk
you know what i mean i don't want to
hurt anybody
and i'm tired of being hurt
so i really feel in my heart that i'm
being released
from skid row i do
because i know that there was a reason
why i was here
and i've and not to toot my own horn or
anything like that but i have touched a
lot of people
you know whether it was good bad or
indifferent
these [ __ ] are gonna remember
me
do you know what i mean they will
they'll remember me
and i will remember every single one of
them
and i hope that one day after i get out
of here
matter of fact i know that i'm gonna
come back here i'm gonna give back
because
ironically enough right before i even
came out here
i used to i used to feed the homeless on
thanksgiving
and now i'm the one being fed oh
thanksgiving
does that feel [ __ ] up
so i remember my first thanksgiving out
here i think
i just cried and cried and cried and
cried
and these last these last two
thanksgivings and um
and christmases have been extra cold and
raining and
messed up you know
and everybody out here is a scavenger
you know and and
and and these organizations don't really
have enough
for everybody you know i think a lot of
a lot of my viewers don't understand
the number of people that are out here
okay they see
200 videos on my channel like oh my god
there's 200 people down there
[ __ ] no there's there's i think 200 000
and i'm just picking the ones that are
the most interesting it's
you know when they say we want you to
help this person what about the other 10
000 that are just like her
right you know of that that one person
you think
we're going to help you're you're bot
you're you're
ignoring the other nine 999
there's so many others they're just like
her well what they need to do is they
need to come and
see for themselves and and then again
this goes on in every state of the
country
not to the same extent that it is here
in maybe san francisco and l.a
absolutely not you know seattle portland
all have really terrible
homeless communities but so does new
york new jersey chicago
they have the river in orange county too
the river
the riverbed people yeah so it's it's
it's all over the country and it's
getting worse and
and but it's bad though there's a lot
and it's to an extreme because
i believe that this is where a lot of
the sh all the crap
originated from you know you hear all
kinds of stories i heard i heard
i heard a story from og the other day he
had said
you know the reason because the rats are
aggressive out here they're not just
regular rats
the i call the rats gangbangers i
they're not regular rats and uh and uh
an
older older guy told me they're very
bold you know the reason why they're
bold like that
is because in the 80s we were feeding
them crack
[Music]
said what shut the hell up
he said no for real and if you look it
up even on youtube and i looked it up on
youtube because i wanted to see what he
was talking about right
if they've done they've done experiments
on
rats with crack cocaine and they will
keep going back
for that crack over and over and over
again
they get addicted very quickly and
they're bigger
than normal man
i was standing in front of the store
right and i had just
oh my friend had just bought me a
hamburger i was really hungry too
and i took a bite of it right and i put
it on the wall i had wrapped it up and
put it on the wall
because i had to tie my shoe to fix my
backpack right
this big rat came out
and just took my hamburger off the wall
like even the rats are scavengers like
even the rats
are gangbangers like they will bite
holes in your tent
oh yeah they will go in your tent and
eat your food
hey just when you think that
everything's okay
and because you got all these rat traps
around no they're
they're like they're hybrid rats or
something like
something's wrong it's crazy out here
it's crazy
so i'm ready to go i i was not
this is not the kind of life that i want
well i'm so happy to hear you speak like
this because
last time we spoke you weren't really as
driven to change your situation no i
really thought that i was gonna die out
here yeah
no and that kind of positivity that
readiness for success is to me the most
important part of recovery
you need to want
and just not just want but like be
driven
to succeed and to be fulfilled and to be
to have a good life and
i hear that in your voice now and you
you'll be the first
addict that we do it that that i'm
involved in doing a donation campaign
for
because everything you're saying tells
me that you can do it
yeah well whereas everyone else i've
spoken to that's an addict it's like
they're ready to stay right where
they're at
they enjoy it they enjoy it they're
they're not they might say they want
recovery
i don't even like to go in other
people's tents yeah
the only time i go into anybody else's
tent
is if it's clean or i'm absolutely
desperate
no you're coming around you're coming
you're coming back to the world
do you know what i mean and then i try
to encourage
others and they all have excuse effort
excuse after excuse like i feel
free this is freedom i feel good out
here and
this man tell me the other day that
he left his dad's birthday party
right to go get a pack of cigarettes
ended up downtown and hasn't been home
in 10 years
you have a home
that you can go to right now
and you're choosing methamphetamines in
this nasty ass
tent with this dirty ass dog
over being home because it feels like
home to them it feels like where they
belong
and what's great about listening to you
talk today is
it's very clear that you feel like you
don't belong here any longer i don't
yeah [ __ ] [ __ ] that [ __ ] i want to go
back to work
and i want to start doing my nails again
and
feeling good about myself again because
that that's that's where i lost to that
you know
mark because i i lost my self-worth
that's how this happens right because
women get discouraged
right and then these men keep them all
keep them all drugged up
and all i want to do is screw on them
and
keep them locked up in a tent you know
i've even seen women in cages before
mark
it's bad out here no
oh no not me
i can't i can't
i can't well anyway um
one of the things that um
a lot of the viewers wanted to do was
hear me sing
i love you now that i'm out now that i'm
blessed i don't even know what to say
anything um
oh here i got one
this is from the the movie fighting
temptations
and um it's actually a christian movie
and they have a choir
or whatever but um
beyonce has a part that's like awesome
and i've actually sung this while
walking down the street before
you know in the middle of the night cold
as hell
because one thing
music makes me happy remember how i said
that in my last
my last video as long as i got my music
in my alcohol and my cigarettes i'm
straight well
as long as i have music like because
what it does is it never lets me down
right it never lets me down and it helps
me
feel you know
i'm no longer numb because it's
something that i love
you know it's it's
it's something i love so i will sing
in the middle of the day in the middle
of the night
at the top of my lungs i don't give a
damn i'm going to sing
but she says especially because of what
she says she says um
excuse me i smoke a lot of new ports
that's one thing i have not quit
she said um
i used to wake up
some days and wish i had stayed asleep
cause i went to bed on top of the world
today the world's on top of me
everybody's got opinions you only been
in my position
so i laugh at the world when i hear what
they
have to say about me feels like i
always fall short of being unworthy
cause i ain't good enough but you still
love me
i ain't no superstar that's why the life
ain't shining on me cause i ain't good
enough
but you still love me i'm not perfect
[Music]
yes i do wrong i've been trying my best
but
it ain't good enough shut my
world if i don't succeed
though i ain't good enough
he still loves me
man that's like
one of my favorite songs
we're gonna do something to help you out
all right
what are we gonna do you gotta help me
up i got hurt
thank you
you